Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
WE HAVE $10 MILLION IN SALES.
NO!
YOU GUYS EXAGGERATE
EVERYTHING.
IT LOOKS EXACTLY
LIKE ME!
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
[ GASPS ]
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
YOU'VE GOT A GOOD IDEA.
JUST GO FOR IT.
I REALLY LIKE YOU, BARBARA.
I LIKE YOU, TOO, BABY!
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
BE QUIET. SO RUDE.
THANK YOU.
IT DOESN'T MATTER!
I'M NOT RUDE.
OUT!
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
WE'RE FIGURING IT OUT.
WE'RE REALLY YOUNG.
WE JUST GRADUATED --
THE "WE'RE REALLY YOUNG"
EXCUSE -- EH, DON'T WORK.
HOW DO YOU SCALE IT?
I'M NOT AT ALL INTERESTED
IN THE MONEY.
AAH!
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT
FROM WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIERE
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
I'M LIZZIE.
I'M MADELINE.
AND I'M BEATRICE.
AND OUR BUSINESS
IS CALLED ZOOM.
THE THREE OF US MET
IN COLLEGE,
ACTUALLY,
IN OUR FIRST DESIGN CLASS,
AND IT WAS KIND OF
LOVE AT FIRST SIGHT,
AND WE'VE BEEN
TOGETHER EVER SINCE.
AT SCHOOL, WE CAME UP
WITH AN AWESOME BUSINESS IDEA
BASED ON HIGH STYLE
AND IMPECCABLE DESIGN.
PEOPLE THINK YOU HAVE
TO SPEND A LOT OF MONEY
TO GET A GOOD DESIGN,
BUT THAT'S
SO NOT THE CASE.
WE FIGURED OUT A NEW WAY
TO BRING STYLE TO EVERYONE
AND MAKE IT AFFORDABLE
AND ACCESSIBLE.
WE GRADUATED A FEW WEEKS AGO
AND MOVED TO PHILLY
AND HAVE OFFICIALLY STARTED
OUR BUSINESS.
EACH OF US TAKES ON
A DIFFERENT ROLE IN THE COMPANY.
I'M IN CHARGE
OF MARKETING AND SALES,
AND I'M ALSO
OUR IN-HOUSE ARTIST.
I'M THE
CREATIVE DIRECTOR.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK
OF THIS COLOR COMBO?
AND I TAKE ON
GENERAL OPERATIONS.
WE ARE ON BUDGET,
SO WE'RE GOOD TO GO!
WE HAVE WORKED SO HARD
TO GROW THIS COMPANY
OVER THE PAST YEAR,
AND IT MEANS THE WORLD TO US.
WE HAVE BIG DREAMS,
AND WE WANT TO KEEP WORKING
TOGETHER FOREVER.
WE KNOW
WITH A SHARK ON OUR TEAM,
WE CAN ZOOM PAST
OUR COMPETITION
AND TAKE THIS COMPANY
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
GUESS WHAT, SHARKS.
All:
YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET ZOOMED!
HI, I'M BEATRICE.
I'M MADELINE.
AND I'M LIZZIE.
All:
AND WE ARE THE ZOOM TEAM.
OUR COMPANY
IS ZOOM INTERIORS
AND WE'RE ASKING FOR $100,000
FOR 20% OF OUR COMPANY.
ZOOM INTERIORS IS
AN ONLINE SERVICE
THAT IS GOING TO REVOLUTIONIZE
THE INTERIOR-DESIGN WORLD
BY MAKING IT ACCESSIBLE
AND AFFORDABLE TO EVERYONE.
WE BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE DESERVES
TO BE GRACED
WITH A STYLISH LIVING SPACE
TO ENHANCE THEIR LIVES
AND IT IS OUR MISSION
TO DO JUST THAT.
LET US WALK YOU
THROUGH OUR ZOOM DESIGN PROCESS
FROM START TO FINISH
WITH A RECENT PROJECT.
STEP ONE -- FILL OUT
THE "GET ZOOMED" SURVEY
TO START
THE DESIGN PROCESS.
IT'S QUICK AND PAINLESS.
STEP TWO -- SCHEDULE YOUR FREE
15-MINUTE ZOOM CONSULTATION
OVER THE PHONE OR VIDEO CHAT.
STEP THREE --
RECEIVE YOUR MOOD BOARD,
A.K.A., ZOOM BOARD,
TO BETTER VISUALIZE OUR DESIGN.
STEP FOUR -- WORK WITH
YOUR PERSONAL DESIGNERS
TO PERFECT THE DESIGN
OF YOUR SPACE.
STEP FIVE -- GET YOUR ZOOM CART,
OR FINAL INVENTORY.
STEP SIX -- RECEIVE YOUR
EASY-TO-READ FLOOR PLANS
FOR A SELF-INSTALLATION.
THIS IS THE "BEFORE" PHOTO
FROM THIS PROJECT.
OUR CLIENTS WANTED
A FULL TRANSFORMATION
THAT WOULD MAKE THIS SPACE
BRIGHT, MODERN, AND COLORFUL.
AND LOOK AT THAT --
QUITE A DIFFERENCE.
WOW.
Herjavec: WOW.
HERE ARE
SOME OTHER ZOOM PROJECTS
WITH DIFFERENT BUDGETS
AND STYLES.
Fraser:
THIS BACHELOR CLEARLY NEEDED
SOME HELP WITH HIS BEDROOM.
WHERE IS THAT,
A PRISON SOMEWHERE?
NO, I THINK IT LOOKS GOOD.
WHY WOULD YOU RUIN IT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, WELL JUST WAIT!
HERE'S THE "AFTER."
HE WANTED
AN URBAN-INDUSTRIAL LOOK.
WHOA!
WE TRANSFORMED IT
FOR $1,000.
WOW.
Corcoran: IMPOSSIBLE.
SO THIS NEXT CLIENT STILL HAD
HER COLLEGE FUTON.
SHE WANTED A GLAMOROUS,
SHABBY-CHIC BEDROOM
THAT WOULD MATCH
HER NEW ADULT LIFE.
WE GAVE THAT TO HER
FOR $1,700.
OH, I LIKE THAT.
OH, THAT'S NICE.
YEAH.
THE INTERIOR DESIGN WORLD
IS SHIFTING ONLINE
AND WE PLAN TO BE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THIS MOVEMENT.
WITH YOUR HELP, WE CAN TAKE THIS
COMPANY TO THE NEXT LEVEL...
All: AT ZOOM SPEED!
O'Leary: TELL US
HOW YOU MAKE MONEY, LADIES.
SO WE HAVE SO FAR BEEN
IN BUSINESS 14 MONTHS.
WE STARTED IN COLLEGE
OUR JUNIOR YEAR,
AND WE'RE TESTING
THE WATERS.
TURNS OUT IT DOES WORK,
AND WE'VE GROSSED $186,000.
Corcoran: HOW MUCH OF THAT
DID YOU NET?
DID YOU ACTUALLY GET
ANY MONEY IN YOUR POCKET?
SO -- WE NET $3,000
AT THE END OF THAT YEAR.
HOW DO YOU MAKE MONEY?
DO YOU MAKE MONEY ON THE FEES?
DO YOU MAKE MONEY
ON SELLING THE FURNITURE?
WE'VE STARTED WITH A SERVICE FEE
OF 18% COMMISSION
ON THE COST OF GOODS PURCHASED
FOR OUR CLIENT.
SO I SIGN UP WITH YOU.
WHAT'S MY FEE JUST TO SIGN UP?
SO TO START, $150 AFTER YOU HAVE
OUR FREE ZOOM CONSULTATION.
YOU MEAN YOU TALK TO THEM
BEFORE YOU GET THE $150?
YES.
YES, WE DO.
WHY DON'T CHARGE THAT
FOR THE VIDEO CHAT?
IT'S 15 MINUTES -- SOMETIMES IT
TAKES LESS THAN THAT --
AND IT MAKES THE CLIENT FEEL
LIKE WE'RE AN ACTUAL PERSON.
Cuban: WELL,
WHAT CAN YOU DO IN 15 MINUTES?
I MEAN, YOU SKYPE IN --
Fischel-Bock:
WE HAVE THEIR SURVEYS,
SO WE ACTUALLY HAVE QUESTIONS
READY FOR THEM.
O'Leary:
JUST OUT OF INTEREST,
IF YOU HAVE
A VIDEO OR SKYPE CALL,
HOW MANY FOLLOW THROUGH
TO BECOME REAL CLIENTS?
UM, I WOULD SAY ABOUT 1 IN 8
FILL OUT OUR SURVEY
THAT FOLLOW THROUGH
WITH THE CONSULTATION.
SO WHY DON'T YOU CHARGE THEM
BEFORE YOU DO THE VIDEO CALL?
Cuban: BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT GONNA DO IT --
THAT'S THE ATTRACTION
OF THE INTERNET, YEAH.
'CAUSE THEY DON'T TRUST US YET.
THEY NEED TO
GET ON THE PHONE.
HOW MANY HOURS OF TIME
DO THEY EAT UP
BEFORE YOU ACTUALLY CLOSE OUT
THAT TRANSACTION?
'CAUSE WHERE
YOU'RE GONNA HIT THE WALL
ON THIS DEAL RIGHT AWAY IS,
IF THIS WORKS AND IT SCALES,
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA CLONE YOURSELVES.
LIKE, HOW'S THAT GONNA WORK?
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
WE WANT TO PROGRAM THIS PROCESS
SO THAT WE CAN TAKE OUT
THE MAN-HOURS
THAT WE'RE PUTTING IN RIGHT NOW.
Herjavec: ARE YOU CHANGING
THE BUSINESS MODEL
AWAY FROM MAKING 18%
ON THE FURNITURE?
YES, YES, WE ARE.
RIGHT NOW WE MAKE 18%.
WHEN WE START WORKING
WITH THESE MANUFACTURERS,
WE'LL BE MAKING 55%.
YEAH, BUT THEN YOU
HAVE TO TAKE INVENTORY.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. WAIT, WAIT.
LET ME GET THIS ONE THING OUT,
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT --
THAT'S NOT THE PROBLEM.
HANG ON. HANG ON. YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW THE PROBLEM YET.
HOW DO YOU SCALE IT?
WHAT DOES IT MATTER
IF THEY MAKE 18% OR 20%?
ONE AT A TIME!
AAH!
EXCUSE ME.
IT'S IRRELEVANT.
STOP!
SHE'S A LADY.
LET HER SPEAK.
BE QUIET.
THANK YOU.
IT DOESN'T MATTER!
WAIT, JUST CALM.
IT'LL NEVER WORK.
SO RUDE.
I'M NOT RUDE.
OH, MY GOD.
WELCOME TO "SHARK TANK."
[ LAUGHTER ]
STOP!
WHO CARES?
Herjavec: WELL,
THEY'RE GOING TO 55%.
OKAY, WAIT A MINUTE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT, THOUGH.
NO, IT ISN'T.
[ SIGHS ]
WHERE I THINK
YOU'RE SAYING YOU MAKE MONEY --
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
I UNDERSTAND THIS --
IS YOU'RE GONNA WORK DIRECT
TO MANUFACTURERS
AND YOU'RE, LIKE,
A WHOLESALER, ESSENTIALLY.
YEAH.
IF A CHAIR COSTS 10 BUCKS...
WE'LL MAKE THAT 50%.
...YOU'RE GONNA BUY IT FOR
10 BUCKS FROM THE MANUFACTURER
AND YOU'RE GONNA TURN AROUND
AND SELL IT FOR 20 OR 25
OR WHATEVER IT IS.
EXACTLY. EXACTLY.
YES.
SO THAT'S WHERE
YOU'RE PLANNING TO MAKE MONEY.
AND THAT'S JUST STARTED
RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT'S WHY IT MATTERS.
NO, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
GET BACK TO WHAT DOES MATTER.
OKAY.
HOW DO YOU SCALE IT?
CAN YOU ANSWER THAT QUESTION?
ARE YOU GONNA TALK
TO EVERY SINGLE PERSON --
IF YOU WERE LISTENING
WHEN I ASKED HER --
Fraser: NO, WE WON'T.
NO, NO, BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA TAKE OUT...
NO.
...THOSE MAN-HOURS
SO WE'RE NOT --
WE DON'T HAVE TO BE
15 MINUTES ON THE PHONE
WITH EVERY SINGLE PERSON.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A ROBOT?
NO, WE'RE GONNA DO IT
ON THE COMPUTER.
THERE'S THREE OF US.
WHY WOULD THEY NOT MISS
THAT 15-MINUTE CONSULTATION?
SO, I GET
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO,
AND THAT'S
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO SCALE.
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE --
YOUR SCALABILITY IS DEPENDENT
ON YOU CREATING
A SOFTWARE APPLICATION
THAT YOU THINK MIGHT HAPPEN
IN...SIX MONTHS,
WHEN YOU'D BE LUCKY
TO DO IT IN SIX YEARS?
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE THINKING.
OH.
THAT'S NOT EASY.
$100,000 WON'T EVEN
GET YOU IN THE DOOR.
$200,000, $1 MILLION --
IT'S PRETTY MUCH IMPOSSIBLE.
WELL, WE'VE GOTTEN ESTIMATES
FOR $100,000.
I'M WORKING WITH A COMPANY --
YEAH, TRUST ME.
[ IMITATES BUZZER ]
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
I'M OUT.
SO AFTER I DO THE $150,
IS THERE A MINIMUM FURNITURE BUY
THAT I HAVE TO DO WITH YOU?
IT'S $1,000.
SO OUT OF THE PEOPLE
THAT GIVE YOU $150,
HOW MANY GO
TO THE FURNITURE BUY?
I WOULD SAY 90%.
YEAH.
Herjavec:
OKAY, OUT OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY BUY THE FURNITURE,
WHAT IS THE AVERAGE
PURCHASE PRICE OF FURNITURE?
ABOUT $2,500,
EXACTLY.
OKAY, SO I DON'T SEE A PROBLEM
WITH THE 15 MINUTES
THAT YOU'RE SPENDING
ON THE PHONE.
LET ME TELL YOU WHY.
O'Leary: I DO.
YOU SPEND 15 MINUTES
NOT MAKING MONEY.
OKAY, BUT LADIES,
YOU'RE SPENDING
15 MINUTES ON THE PHONE.
YOU CAN TEACH SOMEBODY ELSE
THAT YOU CAN SUPERVISE.
OF COURSE. YES.
IN 15 MINUTES,
IN AN HOUR BLOCK, THAT'S 4X.
YEAH.
THAT PERSON GENERATES $600.
OF WHICH NONE OF THEM
BUY ANYTHING!
THAT'S GENERATING $600 AN HOUR,
ALMOST 5 GRAND A DAY.
Fischel-Bock: AND WE CAN HIRE
SOMEONE FREELANCE
TO COVER THAT HOUR.
AND IF 90% ARE GOING
TO A FURNITURE BUY --
ROBERT, YOU MADE
A HUGE MISTAKE THERE.
WHY?
THEY DO THE CALL FOR
FREE, WHICH I FORBID
THEM TO EVER DO AGAIN.
EITHER WAY, YOU WANT THE MONEY
TO AUTOMATE THE PROCESS
TO GET RID OF
THE 15-MINUTE CALL, AM I RIGHT?
WE -- WE'RE FIGURING IT OUT.
WE'RE REALLY YOUNG.
YEAH, IF --
WE JUST GRADUATED
THREE WEEKS AGO.
SO WE'VE JUST --
IT'S BEEN A PROCESS.
WE WANT TO LEARN FROM YOU.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A MENTOR.
Cuban: FIRST OF ALL,
YOU'RE NOT THAT YOUNG, RIGHT?
THE -- THE "WE'RE REALLY YOUNG"
EXCUSE -- EH, DON'T WORK.
Fischel-Bock:
WE -- WE'RE FIGURING IT OUT.
WE'RE REALLY YOUNG.
YEAH, IF --
WE JUST GRADUATED
THREE WEEKS AGO.
SO WE'VE JUST --
IT'S BEEN A PROCESS.
WE WANT TO LEARN FROM YOU.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A MENTOR.
Cuban: FIRST OF ALL,
YOU'RE NOT THAT YOUNG, RIGHT?
THE -- THE "WE'RE REALLY YOUNG"
EXCUSE -- EH, DON'T WORK.
YOU'RE OLD ENOUGH
TO DO YOUR THING, RIGHT?
OF COURSE, YES.
THAT'S NOT AN EXCUSE.
YOU GOT TO PRODUCE, RIGHT?
YEAH, AND WE'VE BEEN LEARNING.
WE'VE BEEN GROWING.
Corcoran: I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
MORE ABOUT THE THREE OF YOU.
WHO DOES WHAT?
ARE YOU ALL FULL-TIME?
YES.
SO, WE ARE FULL-TIME.
WE'RE HAVING A GREAT TIME.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA
SUPPORT YOURSELVES?
WE WOULD TAKE
PART-TIME JOBS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF ENERGY.
WE CAN DO IT.
NO!
NO, NO, NO, NO!
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
YOU'VE GOT A GOOD IDEA.
JUST GO FOR IT, RIGHT? GRIND.
WE ARE GOING FOR IT.
YOU GUYS CAN -- THE THREE OF YOU
CAN LIVE TOGETHER.
GO GET SEVEN OTHER ROOMMATES
TO LIVE WITH YOU.
I SLEPT ON THE FLOOR
FOR SIX MONTHS.
SIX GUYS
IN A THREE-BEDROOM APARTMENT.
I HAD ONE TOWEL THAT STOOD UP
IN THE CORNER BY ITSELF, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT WAS NASTY.
IT DIDN'T MATTER.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT
OF THOSE APARTMENTS.
YEAH.
RIGHT, 'CAUSE EVERY MINUTE
YOU SPEND BARTENDING IS
A MINUTE YOU'RE NOT SELLING,
YOU'RE NOT DOING A CONSULTATION,
YOU'RE NOT
GETTING A CLIENT.
Herjavec:
I LIKE THE IDEA,
BUT YOU CAME IN SAYING
YOU'RE GONNA TAKE THE MONEY
AND YOU'RE GONNA SPEND IT
ON APPLICATION DEVELOPMENT.
DON'T -- THE WORST MISTAKE
YOU COULD EVER MAKE.
WELL, IF YOU DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE RIGHT IDEA --
ARE YOU GONNA SPEND IT ON THAT?
IS THAT
WHAT YOUR PLAN IS?
THAT'S OUR PLAN,
BUT WE'RE -- I MEAN, IF --
DON'T.
IF YOU DON'T THINK
THAT WE SHOULD, THEN --
NO, I -- HOLD ON.
I FORBID YOU.
IF YOU WERE US, WHAT WOULD
YOU USE THE MONEY FOR?
IF I WERE YOU GUYS,
I'D GRIND, RIGHT?
RIGHT, YES.
JUST EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW AND KEEP ON GROWING.
I WOULDN'T GET
ANOTHER JOB.
I'D SLEEP ON THE FLOOR.
I'D LIVE LIKE A STUDENT.
I WOULD MAKE SURE I DON'T HAVE
ANY DEBT WHATSOEVER --
NO CREDIT CARD, NO NOTHING,
SO THERE'S NO OTHER OBLIGATIONS,
AND I WOULD HUSTLE.
AND THEN YOU JUST GROW.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO RUSH.
MADELINE, I HATE THE ANSWER
YOU GAVE ON THE PROGRAMMING.
"OKAY, WE WON'T DO IT.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK
WE SHOULD DO?"
I DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO
HELP YOU COME UP WITH THE IDEAS.
I CAN HELP YOU INVEST
AND GROW IT.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
O'Leary:
LOOK, I-I HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM
I HAD WHEN YOU WALKED IN.
I DON'T SEE IT BEING SCALABLE.
I'M SORRY.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES,
YOU HAVE DEAL IN REALITY.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I LOVE THE IDEA,
BUT HEARING EVERYTHING
THAT WE'VE HEARD HERE,
I FEEL LIKE IT'S GONNA BE
A REALLY LONG, HARD ROAD.
AND, TO MARK'S POINT,
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA NEED
A LOT MORE MONEY.
I THINK THERE'S
SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT YOU HAVE TO WORK OUT.
AND I'M SORRY.
I'M OUT.
IT'S OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BARBARA?
[ CHUCKLES ]
I COULD GO EITHER WAY
ON THIS, QUITE HONESTLY.
OKAY.
WHAT I REALLY LIKE ABOUT IT
IS YOUR LOW $150 FEE.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
NOT CHANGE.
I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT ON THE DIME.
Fraser: GREAT.
Corcoran: I ALSO LOVE
YOUR $1,000 MINIMUM.
I'D HATE TO SEE THAT CHANGE
BECAUSE -- ONLY 1,000 BUCKS.
EVERYBODY REMEMBERS IT.
AND I LOVE
YOUR ENERGY AND HUSTLE.
THE BAD NEWS --
I DON'T LIKE THE APPLICATION
DEVELOPMENT PART OF IT AT ALL.
TO MARK'S POINT,
IT COSTS YOU SO MUCH MONEY,
AND YOU'LL BE CONSTANTLY BE
NEEDING TO DO IT.
AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S THE ROAD TO RICHES,
SO I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
OUT OF THE DEAL.
GOOD.
THAT'S FINE WITH US.
GREAT, OKAY, SO
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
OH, WOW.
OOH.
OKAY.
NOW HERE'S
THE BAD NEWS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S NOT BAD NEWS, NO.
I NEED 1/3 OF THE BUSINESS
FOR THE MONEY YOU'RE ASKING.
I WANT TO BE
A 1/3 PARTNER.
$100,000
FOR 33% OF YOUR BUSINESS.
OKAY. SO I GUESS --
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU GOT TO JUMP
ALL OVER THAT.
I REALLY LIKE YOU,
BARBARA.
I LIKE YOU, TOO, BABY.
I LOVE YOUR --
I LOVE YOUR ENERGY.
AND I-I --
I REALLY LIKE THAT.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
I THINK SO, YES.
OKAY, YES.
YEAH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
Fraser: WHOO!
[ CHUCKLES ]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Fischel-Bock: WOMEN
IN BUSINESS -- WE LIKE THAT.
GREAT DRESSES.
CONGRATS, GUYS.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK. CONGRATS.
Fraser: WHOO-HOO!
OH, MY GOD.
THAT WAS CRAZY.
YOU WILL NEVER MAKE
ANY MONEY ON THAT.
I WILL MAKE MONEY.
YES, SHE WILL.
WE NEEDED A MENTOR.
THAT WAS OUR NUMBER-ONE THING
COMING INTO THE GATE,
AND WE'RE SO HAPPY THAT SHE,
YOU KNOW,
WANTS TO MENTOR US
AND WORK WITH US IN THE FUTURE.
AND THE AMOUNT THAT WE'VE GROWN
IN A YEAR ORGANICALLY,
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE WHAT WE CAN
DO WITH BARBARA ON OUR TEAM.
YEAH.
IT'S EXCITING.
Narrator:
EARLIER THIS SEASON,
MOTHER-AND-SON TEAM JUDY
AND BOBBY EDWARDS MADE A DEAL
WITH LORI GREINER
FOR THEIR TOILET STOOL,
SQUATTY POTTY.
WE'RE GONNA
TAKE LORI'S OFFER.
LET'S SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
Greiner: I INVITED BOBBY
AND JUDY TO COME WITH ME
TO BED BATH & BEYOND
AND CHECK OUT OUR NEW DISPLAY.
OH, MY GOSH.
LOOK AT THAT.
WE JUST LAUNCHED
IN EVERY LOCATION NATIONWIDE.
THAT'S OVER 1,100 STORES.
IT'S A TOWER
OF SQUATTY.
Judy:
THE NIGHT WE AIRED,
158,000 PEOPLE VISITED
OUR WEBSITE.
WITHIN TWO DAYS, WE SOLD
$1 MILLION IN SQUATTY POTTIES.
IT'S BEEN THREE MONTHS
SINCE WE AIRED,
AND OUR TOTAL SALES
ARE $12.3 MILLION.
THIS'LL STOP YOU
AS YOU WALK IN THE STORE.
Greiner: ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
WHEN YOU GET INTO A RETAIL STORE
IS WHERE ARE YOU PLACED.
YOU COULD BE
ON THE BOTTOM SHELF.
WE HAVE AN ENTIRE
FLOOR-TO-CEILING DISPLAY.
PEOPLE WOULD DO ANYTHING
TO GET THAT.
LONG WAY FROM OUR GARAGE.
THANK YOU.
Bobby: IN THE BEGINNING,
PEOPLE THOUGHT WE WERE CRAZY
FOR SELLING SUCH A PRODUCT.
HAVING LORI ON OUR TEAM HAS
REALLY VALIDATED SQUATTY POTTY.
Greiner:
LET'S GO CELEBRATE.
Judy: LET'S DO.
Bobby: LET'S GO.
SO, IS THIS WHAT'S GOING TO BE
OUR NEW HOMEPAGE?
THIS IS IT.
I LOVE THE CHANGES.
Bobby: WE'VE MADE IT OUR MISSION
TO CHANGE THE WAY
AMERICA USES THE BATHROOM,
AND WE'RE HERE TO PROVIDE
PRODUCTS TO HELP THEM DO THAT.
AND WE'RE NOT
GONNA QUIT
TILL SQUATTY POTTY
IS A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
CHEERS!
THIS HAS BEEN SUCH
AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE FOR US.
WE CONTINUE TO BE GRATEFUL
EVERY DAY
FOR LORI AND "SHARK TANK."
All: IT'S POTTY TIME!
Narrator: NEXT UP
IS A CONVENIENT WAY
TO MAKE SURE
YOU'RE PROTECTED FROM THE SUN.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS TONY FAYNE.
AND I'M JOSH KAPLAN.
Both: TOGETHER,
WE ARE SUNSCREEN MIST.
SHARKS, WE ARE HERE TODAY
ASKING FOR $400,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 15% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
WE ALL GO OUT
INTO THE SUN,
AND WE ALL NEED TO PROTECT
OURSELF WITH SUNSCREEN,
BUT APPLYING TRADITIONAL
SUNSCREEN IS INCONVENIENT
AND IT'S EASY TO FORGET.
AND IF WE DO APPLY IT,
WELL, MOST OF US ARE
APPLYING IT INCORRECTLY.
BUT DON'T WORRY, SHARKS.
WE'VE GOT YOUR COVERED
WITH OUR AMAZING
NEW SUNSCREEN-MIST MACHINES.
THE FIRST-EVER MACHINE
THAT APPLIES
THE F.D.A.-RECOMMENDED
AMOUNT OF SUNSCREEN
IN JUST SECONDS.
SO NO MORE, "YOU DO MY BACK.
I'LL DO YOUR BACK."
NO MORE "UH-OH,
I MISSED A SPOT."
AND NO MORE
UNEXPLAINED TAN LINES.
SUNSCREEN MIST MACHINES
ARE HERE FOR YOU
WHEN YOU NEED THEM
THE MOST.
WE CURRENTLY OFFER TWO MODELS --
OUR BOOTHS AND STATIONS.
THE BOOTH IS OPERATED
IN JUST THREE EASY STEPS.
STEP ONE
IS INSERT PAYMENT.
NOW, WE ACCEPT MANY
DIFFERENT PAYMENT OPTIONS --
CASH, CREDIT.
WE CAN EVEN PROGRAM OUR MACHINES
TO ACCEPT HOTEL ROOM KEYS.
STEP TWO IS
CHOOSE YOUR LOTION.
AND STEP THREE IS
CLOSE YOUR EYES
AND RECEIVE A FULL-BODY MIST
IN JUST SECONDS.
Herjavec: THAT'S IT?
AMBER IS NOW PROTECTED
FROM HEAD TO TOE.
THERE'S NO NEED TO RUB IN
SUNSCREEN MIST.
IS YOUR STOMACH COVERED?
ANDY AND MORGAN
ARE GONNA DEMONSTRATE
OUR SUNSCREEN MIST
STATIONS,
WHICH ARE PERFECT FOR PLACES
SUCH AS THEME PARKS,
ZOOS, OUTDOOR FESTIVALS,
OR GOLF COURSES.
YOU SIMPLY POINT
AND PROTECT.
DON'T WORRY
ABOUT THE CLOTHING --
SUNSCREEN MIST LOTIONS
ARE MADE
WITH A PURIFIED-WATER
AND ALOE-VERA BASE
SO THEY WON'T STAIN
OUR CLOTHING.
SHARKS, THE SUN SHINES
SOMEWHERE 24 HOURS A DAY.
AND WITH THE RIGHT PARTNER
ON BOARD,
YOU CAN HELP US
PROTECT THE WORLD.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN USING SUNSCREEN
FOR DECADES.
THEY NEVER HAD A PROBLEM
APPLYING IT.
HAVE YOU JUST SOLVED A PROBLEM
THAT DOESN'T EXIST?
I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION.
FOR DECADES,
SKIN CANCER HAS BEEN RISING,
AND IT IS NOW
THE MOST POPULAR FORM OF CANCER.
SO YOU'RE SUGGESTING EVERYBODY'S
PUTTING IT ON INCORRECTLY,
AND FINALLY A SHOWER
IN THE MIDDLE OF A BEACH
IS GONNA SOLVE IT?
IT'S INCREASING POINT-OF-ACCESS
FOR CONSUMERS.
BUT HER STOMACH DIDN'T GET
ANY OF THE LOTION.
Corcoran: THERE'S
NO SHINE ON HER STOMACH.
IT DIDN'T COVER HER ENTIRE BODY.
YEAH, IT DIDN'T LOOK
LIKE HER STOMACH HAD GOTTEN IT.
SO THE MACHINES
ARE ACTUALLY DESIGNED
FOR WHERE THEY'RE GOING, SO WE
CAN PROGRAM THE AMOUNT OF TIME,
AND THEY ALSO CHANGE IN DEPTH
AND IN POWER OF THE SPRAY JETS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OF THESE OUT
THERE IN THE MARKET ANYWHERE?
WE ABSOLUTELY DO.
GO AHEAD, TONY.
SURE.
YEAH, WE HAVE THEM
IN NEW YORK,
IN NEW JERSEY, FLORIDA.
SO YOU HAVE IT ON A BEACH
AS A STAND-ALONE UNIT?
YEAH, IT'S TERRIFIC.
AND TELL ME --
HOW MUCH DO I PAY?
DEPENDING WHERE IT'S PLACED,
IT WILL COST ANYWHERE
FROM $1 TO $5.
IF YOU'RE
AT A LAS VEGAS POOL,
YOU'RE PROBABLY GONNA PAY
CLOSER TO $5,
'CAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WATER COSTS.
$5 FOR A SUNSCREEN?
WHY DON'T I JUST BUY
A BOTTLE OF SUNSCREEN?
Herjavec: BUT, JOSH,
WALK US THOUGH IT.
WHO PAID FOR THE MACHINE
TO GET THERE?
THEY EITHER -- EXACTLY.
DOES THE HOTEL BUY
THE MACHINE FROM YOU?
THERE'S
TWO DIFFERENT MODELS
THAT WE GO THROUGH
FOR OUR SALES,
SO WE HAVE
EXCLUSIVE DISTRIBUTORS
THAT ACTUALLY
MAKE A COMMITMENT
TO BUY A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF MACHINES.
AND HOW MUCH DOES
THE MACHINE COST?
THE STATION,
WE WHOLESALE FOR $6,990,
AND RETAIL IT
FOR $14,000.
$14,000?
CORRECT.
NO!
OHH!
YEAH, CORRECT. THE DUAL --
FOR THE STAND-ALONE ONE?
FOR THE ONE-SPRAY.
THE TWO-SPRAY...
Greiner: THE LITTLE SPRAYER.
...WE WHOLESALE IT
FOR $8,490,
AND WE RETAIL IT
FOR $17,000 APPROXIMATELY.
AND TWO-SPRAY MEANS IT
JUST GIVES YOU TWO SPRAYS.
TWO LOTION CHOICES,
CORRECT.
YOU MEAN THAT BIG BOOTH
IS $17,000?
OHH.
NO, THE BOOTH, WE ACTUALLY
WHOLESALE FOR $12,700
AND WE RETAIL
FOR $31,2-- $31,500.
$31,000?!
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S 31,000 SPRAYS
JUST TO GET THE MONEY BACK.
WELL,
WE ALSO HAVE DONE
$325,000 IN THE LAST THREE
MONTHS WITH THESE MACHINES.
SO THAT'S 12 UNITS
AT BASIC--
I BELIEVE IT WAS
SEVEN DIFFERENT CUSTOMERS.
SO I CAN BUY A USED HELICOPTER,
OR I CAN BUY THIS.
Greiner: WAIT, SAY WHAT --
YOU WERE SAYING
THAT YOU WERE IN NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, FLORIDA.
YES.
SO WHO WAS PAYING FOR IT
IN THOSE PLACES?
WELL, RECENTLY, WE HAD
THE GOVERNOR'S BALL IN NEW YORK.
WE HAD 1,300 CUSTOMERS
IN JUST TWO DAYS.
1,300 CUSTOMERS
IN TWO DAYS.
BUT HOW DOES THAT ANSWER
LORI'S QUESTION?
THE OWNER OF THAT MACHINE
ACTUALLY TAKES THE MACHINE
TO DIFFERENT EVENTS
IN THAT AREA,
SO THAT WAS ONE OF THE EVENTS
THAT THEY HAD THE MACHINE.
Cuban: OKAY,
SO YOU'RE BASICALLY BEING
LIKE THE ATM BUSINESS,
BASICALLY,
WHERE YOU'RE GONNA LEASE THIS,
SELL THIS TO SOME "ENTREPRENEUR"
IN SOME LOCATION,
AND THEN IT'S THEIR JOB
TO FIND THE LOCATIONS
TO HOST THIS
AND THEN HOPE THEY GET
ENOUGH CUSTOMERS TO PAY IT BACK.
THAT'S ONE SIDE
OF THE BUSINESS MODEL.
THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE BUSINESS MODEL IS
WE ALSO WILL DEAL DIRECT
WITH LARGE CORPORATIONS.
TELL ME ONE LARGE COMMERCIAL
OR ENTERPRISE COMPANY --
A CRUISE LINE OR HOTEL.
THAT PAYS.
MGM GRAND.
THAT'S ACTUALLY PAID YOU
FOR IT.
SO, MGM GRAND
BOUGHT A BOOTH.
MGM GRAND IN LAS VEGAS.
WE DID A PROOF OF CONCEPT
FOR A FEW YEARS.
IT WENT WONDERFUL.
"YEARS"?
WE HAD --
WE HAD TWO YEARS, YEAH.
WE DID APPROXIMATELY 250 PEOPLE
A DAY ON OUR HIGH END.
BUT THEY REDID THEIR --
THEIR ENTIRE POOL-DECK AREA.
AND SO, WHEN THEY REDID IT,
WE WANTED TO PULL BACK.
O'Leary: IN TERMS OF GETTING
MASSIVE DISTRIBUTION QUICKLY,
THERE ARE COMPANIES
THAT ACTUALLY DEVELOP
BIG VENDING PROGRAMS.
THEY PUT IT
INTO A LEASING PROGRAM
FOR RETAILERS AND POOL OPERATORS
AND OUTDOOR GUYS.
AND YOU JUST SIT BACK
AND COLLECT YOUR PIECE,
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
A ROYALTY LICENSING DEAL.
WHY NOT DO THAT?
Kaplan:
WE ARE ACTUALLY IN TALKS
WITH ONE OF
THE LARGEST COMPANIES
THAT DOES THAT WITH HOTEL CHAINS
ALL ACROSS THE WORLD.
OKAY.
WE WELCOMED THEM IN
WITH OPEN ARMS.
BUT IF IT'S SOMEBODY ELSE
THAT'S JUST SOMEBODY
THAT GRINDS LIKE MYSELF --
I'VE BEEN GRINDING SINCE
I WAS 14 YEARS OLD --
THAT THINKS THEY CAN GO
OUT THERE AND GET 12 CUSTOMERS
ON DAY 1
AND BUY 12 MACHINES,
THEN WE WOULD LOVE TO
BE ABLE TO SELL TO THEM.
I'VE BEEN LISTENING
VERY INTENTLY,
AND YOU KNOW
HOW I FEEL ABOUT IT?
IT FEELS SO, SO COMPLICATED,
THIS WHOLE THING.
THE WHOLE BUSINESS PLAN
FEELS COMPLICATED.
THAT MACHINE IS SO LARGE,
I CAN'T IMAGINE YOU SELLING
ANY MORE, HONESTLY.
THE SMALLER MACHINE, EVEN THOUGH
IT LOOKS SMALL BY COMPARISON,
IS STILL TOO BIG.
I'M OUT.
Herjavec: OKAY, SO, I MEAN,
I HEAR YOU GUYS TALKING
ABOUT THIS ROUTE
AND FRANCHISES.
I CAN'T -- I CAN'T FOLLOW
THE BOUNCING BALL.
I'M OUT.
I APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTARY.
HOPEFULLY, OVER THE REST
OF THE PITCH, YOU RECONSIDER.
THANK YOU.
YOU GUYS EXAGGERATE
EVERYTHING.
YOU TALK ABOUT RETAIL,
YET YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY RETAIL CUSTOMERS.
THERE'S NOBODY AT RETAIL
TO SELL TO, RIGHT?
WELL, WE'RE WORKING
ON A RESIDENTIAL --
NO, BUT SEE, THERE YOU GO
AGAIN, RIGHT? BECAUSE --
WE'VE HAD REQUESTS.
NO DOUBT YOU HAVE.
[ LAUGHS ]
Fayne: RIGHT.
THERE IS NO MARKET AT ALL
THAT YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW
FOR RETAIL.
WE'VE JUST BEEN OPERATING
THIS BUSINESS FOR 3 1/2 MONTHS.
THE REASON
WHY WE NEED TO PARTNER --
YOU HAD IT FOR TWO YEARS
ON PROOF OF CONCEPT.
THAT WAS NOT FULL TIME.
THAT WAS BEFORE WE KNEW
WE WANTED TO COMMIT
OUR CAREERS TO IT.
SO --
[ LAUGHS, SHUDDERS ]
SO YOU GUYS PUT IT ON --
WE PROVED THE CONCEPT --
I GOT TO ROLL UP
MY PANT LEGS.
AND IT'S JUST LIKE --
WHAT YOU JUST SAID THERE
IS THE PERFECT, PERFECT
EMBODIMENT OF WHO YOU GUYS ARE.
YOU'VE MADE SOMEBODY PAY YOU
TO DO A PROOF OF CONCEPT
THAT LASTED TWO YEARS
BEFORE YOU WERE EVEN SURE
YOU WERE GOING TO BE
IN THE BUSINESS, RIGHT?
I -- MARK, I --
MARK, JUST SAY, "I'M OUT."
I APPRECIATE ALL OF THE INPUT.
"I'M OUT."
AND THE REASON IS BECAUSE
WE'RE GETTING HUNDREDS
OF REQUESTS A DAY
TO SELL THE PRODUCT.
DO YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
COMING TO YOU A DAY
TO BUY THE MACHINE?
WE GET HUNDREDS OF LEADS THROUGH
THESE MESSAGE BOARDS A DAY.
WHICH MESSAGE BOARD
ARE YOU ON?
WELL, QUITE FRANKLY,
UM, THE --
THE INTERNET SEARCHES
HAS JUST BEEN ORGANIC
BY POSTING P.R., WEB...
AAH! I'M OUT.
...PRESS RELEASES.
I AM SO OUT! I AM SO OUT!
THANK GOD HE'S OUT!
I'M SO OUT.
OH, MY GOSH.
IT IS A SIMPLE QUESTION!
WHAT INTERNET MESSAGE
BOARDS WERE YOU ON?
AND THEN YOU START TALKING
ABOUT ORGANIC SEARCHES.
BECAUSE I WASN'T INVOLVED
IN MESSAGE-BOARDING.
I THINK MR. CUBAN IS OUT.
Greiner: THIS, TO ME,
IS ALL ABOUT CONVENIENCE.
IT'S NOT REALLY
RE-EDUCATING THE PUBLIC.
LORI, I-I --
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PROOF OF CONCEPT
FOR ME.
I WISH YOU HAD COME IN
AND HAD SAID,
"WE HAVE AN INTERCONTINENTAL
HOTEL CHAIN,"
OR "WE HAVE" SOMETHING
WHERE I KNEW IT WAS WORKING.
AT THE MOMENT,
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PROOF OF CONCEPT,
I'M OUT.
LET'S IMAGINE WE WALK INTO A ZOO
OR A THEME PARK, OKAY?
WE APPLY OUR SUNSCREEN,
AND AN HOUR AND A HALF LATER,
THE SUN IS BEATING DOWN,
AND YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU ARE REALLY GETTING RED.
NO, I THINK WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THAT MODEL.
SO, WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS PROVIDE THE CONVENIENCE --
LOOK, GUYS --
THE OTHER THING,
MR. WONDERFUL --
LOOK, I'M LOOKING AT IT
SAYING --
LET HIM FINISH HIS SENTENCE.
LET ME FINISH MY SENTENCE.
NO. YOU'RE SO RUDE.
HE DIDN'T INTERRUPT YOU.
I'M OUT! I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
MR. WONDERFUL,
GO BACK THREE WORDS.
I WANT TO HERE
YOUR SENTENCE.
I'M OUT. WHO'S IN?
Cuban: WHO'S LEFT?
NOBODY.
BYE, GUYS. GOOD LUCK.
BARBARA AND LORI,
IF THERE IS ANY WAY
YOU WILL RECONSIDER
BEING OUT --
NO.
IF THERE IS ANY WAY --
YEAH, GUYS, COME ON!
Greiner: YOU GUYS...
YOU'VE GOT --
...I APPRECIATE IT, BUT...
Corcoran: THANK YOU.
LORI, STOP.
Herjavec: LORI.
LORI.
[ Chuckling ] YOU BETTER GO.
THANK YOU.
GUYS, I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
O'Leary: THANK YOU.
Cuban: GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
Herjavec: THANK YOU.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
Kaplan:
THE TANK IS REALLY HARD.
I'VE BEEN IN
A LOT OF ATMOSPHERES,
DONE A LOT OF PITCHES.
IT'S VERY HARD TO STAY COOL
AND CONSISTENT.
WE DID OUR BEST.
WHAT CAN YOU SAY?
WOW.
EVERY TIME
I ASKED A SIMPLE QUESTION,
HE GAVE ME EVERYTHING
BUT THE ANSWER.
YEAH, BUT YOU TOTALLY
LOST YOUR COOL.
MARK, IN THIS CASE
YOU WERE DEAD ON.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A SCIENTIST WITH A WAY
TO MAKE MEDICAL TESTING
MORE HUMANE AND EFFECTIVE.
GREETINGS, ORGANIC HUMANS.
KEVIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
MY NAME IS
DR. CHRISTOPHER SAKEZLES.
I AM THE FOUNDER
AND C.E.O. OF SynDaver LABS,
AND I'M SEEKING $3 MILLION
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 10% OF MY COMPANY.
SynDaver LABS DESIGNS AND BUILDS
THE WORLD'S MOST SOPHISTICATED
SYNTHETIC HUMAN TISSUES
AND BODY PARTS.
MADE FROM SALT, WATER,
AND FIBER, JUST LIKE YOU AND I,
OUR PRODUCTS EMPLOY MATERIALS
THAT MIMIC THE PROPERTIES
OF HUMAN TISSUE.
THESE PRODUCTS ARE USED
THROUGHOUT THE MEDICAL INDUSTRY
TO REPLACE LIVE ANIMALS,
HUMAN CADAVERS,
AND EVEN HUMAN PATIENTS
IN TRAUMA TRAINING,
SURGICAL EDUCATION,
AND MEDICAL-DEVICE DEVELOPMENT.
OUR FLAGSHIP PRODUCT
IS WHAT YOU SEE HERE.
IT'S THE SynDaver
SYNTHETIC HUMAN.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
DO PRACTICALLY ANY SURGERY ON.
SO, WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
GET A FEW VOLUNTEERS
TO COME DOWN
AND TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
YEAH, I'D LIKE TO SEE IT.
I'D LIKE TO LOOK AT IT.
ALL RIGHT,
I'M DYING TO SEE IT, TOO.
SO, YOU CAN FEEL
THAT IT'S MOIST.
THIS IS ABOUT 85% WATER
BY MASS.
IT HAS EVERY MUSCLE,
BONE, AND ORGAN
IN NATURAL HUMAN ANATOMY.
Greiner: IT ALMOST FEELS
LIKE CHICKEN -- RAW CHICKEN.
Sakezles: IT FEELS EXACTLY
LIKE LIVE TISSUE.
WE'VE SPENT
ABOUT 20 YEARS DOING
THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE TISSUES ITSELF.
AND HOW DO YOU DO SURGERY ON IT?
CAN YOU CUT IT?
YOU CAN CUT IT.
IT'S BASICALLY
A BIG 3-D JIGSAW PUZZLE.
OOH, WOW.
IT'S A BRAND-NEW SYSTEM.
IT'S A CADAVER-LIKE
ALTERNATIVE.
YES, SIR.
Herjavec: WHAT'S THE PRICE POINT
COMPARED TO A CADAVER?
IT COSTS A LOT MORE.
THIS DOES?
'CAUSE THIS IS REUSABLE.
A CADAVER'S NOT.
HOW MUCH IS THIS?
A CADAVER WILL COST YOU
5 GRAND,
10 GRAND DEPENDING
ON WHERE YOU ARE.
THIS IS A $40,000 MODEL,
BUT YOU KEEP IT FOREVER.
[ GASPS ]
OH, DO -- DO IT AGAIN.
OH, MY GOD.
THAT WAS COOL.
MAKE THE EYES CLOSE.
GOD. FREAKY.
Sakezles: THIS ONE IS CALLED
THE ANIMAE.
Herjavec: DO IT AGAIN.
AAH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO SIT DOWN
AND LISTEN.
RELAX.
YOU'RE GOOD, RIGHT?
Greiner:
TELL US ABOUT YOUR COMPANY.
WELL, WE STARTED IN MY GARAGE
ABOUT 10 YEARS AGO.
I DIDN'T THINK DOCTORS
STARTED IN GARAGES.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS
FOR TECH PEOPLE.
WELL, I'M A PhD.
I'M A PhD DOCTOR.
PhD IN WHAT?
POLYMER SCIENCE.
MY MASTERS
IS MATERIAL SCIENCE,
AND MY BACHELOR'S
IS MECHANICAL ENGINEERING.
I USED TO DO
A LOT OF ANIMAL TESTING.
THE EXPENSE THAT'S ASSOCIATED
WITH ANIMAL STUDIES
IS PRETTY HORRENDOUS.
WHY?
JUST BECAUSE OF ALL
THE ASSOCIATED PROFESSIONALS
THAT GO WITH IT --
THE ANESTHESIOLOGISTS,
VETERINARIANS,
THE FACILITIES YOU HAVE TO HAVE
TO HOUSE THEM.
IT'S INTERESTING STUFF. YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR $3 MILLION FOR 10%.
YOU'RE VALUING THE COMPANY
AT $30 MILLION.
YOU MUST HAVE SOME SALES.
WE HAVE $10 MILLION
IN SALES.
WHOA.
Greiner: WOW.
CHRIS, YOUR SALES
WERE $10 MILLION
IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS?
$10 MILLION LIFETIME.
LIFETIME.
SO THAT'S MOSTLY
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
WE DID $5 MILLION
THIS YEAR.
BUT HOW SHOULD I VALUE
YOUR BUSINESS.
WELL, WE'VE GOT SALES
THAT ARE DOUBLING EVERY YEAR.
WE'RE ALSO PART OF A JOINT
VENTURE THAT'S VYING FOR,
YOU KNOW, $150 MILLION
IN U.S. BUSINESS NEXT YEAR.
IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
THAT'S DOING THIS?
WE ARE THE ONLY COMPANY
IN THE WORLD THAT DOES THIS,
AND WE HAVE 10 ISSUED PATENTS
THAT COVER THE TECHNOLOGY.
O'Leary: SO, I'M FAMILIAR WITH
THE MEDICAL-DEVICE SECTOR.
I INVEST IN IT,
AND THE PUBLIC COMPANIES
THAT ARE A HUNDRED TIMES
LARGER THAN YOU
TRADE BETWEEN 11 AND 20 TIMES
THEIR FREE CASH.
THAT'S THE RANGE.
I MEAN, WE COULD BE MAKING QUITE
A BIT OF MONEY IF I WANTED TO.
WHOA.
WHY DO YOU NOT WANT TO?
WELL, THAT'S A GOOD THING.
'CAUSE HE WANTS TO KEEP ON
GROWING THE COMPANY.
I'M NOT AT ALL INTERESTED
IN THE MONEY.
IT'S JUST A TOOL TO ME
THAT I USE TO HIRE PEOPLE.
YOU'RE NOT INTERESTED
IN MAKING MONEY?
THAT'S NOT MY MOTIVATION.
MEDICAL TRAINING
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
IT'S A WAY TO SAVE LIVES.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE PROFITS?
DO YOU CARE ABOUT THOSE?
I WILL AT SOME POINT.
THAT'S NOT ENCOURAGING WORDS
TO AN INVESTOR.
YOU WANT ME TO GIVE YOU
$3 MILLION FOR 10%.
YOU'RE IMPUTING
A $30 MILLION VALUE ON IT.
WELL, THAT'S BASED
ON THE ASSUMPTION
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
MUCH MORE VALUABLE LATER ON.
EVERYBODY THAT COMES
IN THE SHARK TANK SAYS THAT
WHETHER THEY'RE SELLING CANDY
OR DEAD GUYS.
HERE'S WHAT DOESN'T ADD UP
FOR ME.
I GOT TO BELIEVE YOU'RE ONE OF
THE TOP GUYS IN THIS FIELD.
I'M THE WORLD LEADER
IN THIS FIELD, YEAH.
OKAY.
WHY AREN'T PEOPLE BEATING
A PATH TO YOUR DOOR?
Corcoran:
HE'S MISSING A BUSINESSMAN.
YOU NEED A BUSINESSMAN TO
MAKE MONEY, AND YOU'RE NOT HIM.
BUT YOU CANNOT
BUILD A BUSINESS
UNLESS YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN MAKING A PROFIT.
I'M OUT.
OKAY. WELL, THANK YOU.
UM, I DON'T AGREE
WITH YOUR STATEMENT
THAT I'M NOT INTERESTED
IN PROFIT.
I WOULD SAY THAT IT IS NOT
WHAT I'M INTERESTED IN
RIGHT NOW.
TOP PRIORITY.
BUT THINK ABOUT HOW THAT SOUNDS
TO AN INVESTOR.
Greiner: RIGHT.
Herjavec: YOU KNOW WHAT?
TO ME IT SOUNDS
ABSOLUTELY LOGICAL
AND REASONABLE.
'CAUSE YOU'RE GONNA LOOK
LIKE THAT THING ON THE TABLE
BEFORE YOU GET
YOUR MONEY BACK.
THAT IS NOT TRUE AT ALL.
WELL, WHEN AM I GETTING
MY MONEY BACK?
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
WELL, THAT'S
A GOOD ANSWER, RIGHT?
YOU WERE RIGHT, CHRIS.
IT'S AN HONEST ANSWER.
CHRIS, YOU WERE RIGHT.
I KEEP ASKING YOU THE QUESTION
15 DIFFERENT WAYS --
WHEN AND HOW DO I GET
MY MONEY BACK?
AND HOW MANY TIMES MULTIPLE
DO I GET?
GET ME EXCITED
ABOUT THAT.
WELL, IT'S -- I DON'T KNOW
THAT I CAN PREDICT
HOW LARGE WE'RE GOING TO BE
BECAUSE IT'S A NEW SECTOR
THAT'S BEEN CREATED.
SEE, YOU DON'T HAVE THAT PASSION
ABOUT DRIVING THE BUSINESS.
AND I UNDERSTAND.
YOU'RE A SCIENTIST.
THIS IS WHAT DRIVES YOU.
BUT FOR ME TO INVEST
IN YOU,
I HAVE TO FEEL THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO PROTECT MY INVESTMENT
AND MAKE IT THRIVE.
AND I DIDN'T HEAR THAT
HERE TODAY.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
O'Leary: THE SALES ARE
A LITTLE UNDERWHELMING
GIVEN THE POTENTIAL
THAT YOU TALK ABOUT.
BUT YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO ARTICULATE
WHAT MY EXPECTATIONS
SHOULD BE.
DON'T YOU SEE THE RISK IN THAT
IN TERMS OF GETTING A DEAL?
I DO.
AND YOU DON'T CARE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I WOULDN'T SAY I DON'T CARE.
I JUST DON'T WANT TO --
LET ME TALK
TO THE DEAD GUY.
I DON'T WANT TO --
I DON'T WANT TO LIE TO YOU.
I'M OUT.
Herjavec:
I'M NOT IN THIS SPACE,
BUT I LIKE COMPLEXITY.
IT'S A BIG BARRIER TO ENTRY
TO OTHER PEOPLE.
I THINK
YOU'RE ON TO SOMETHING.
I THINK WHAT'S MISSING IS SIMPLY
AN AVENUE TO SALES
AND DISTRIBUTION
AND MARKETING.
AND KEVIN'S
PARTLY RIGHT --
YOU SEEM A LITTLE HESITANT
ABOUT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
I'M A SCIENTIST.
I'M -- I'M NOT THAT GUY.
CHRISTOPHER,
HERE'S MY OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $3 MILLION FOR 35%,
AND AN EQUAL
BOARD REPRESENTATION.
I'M NOT TRYING TO CONTROL YOU,
BUT I NEED SOMEBODY
ON THAT BOARD
WHO'S WAKING UP WITH A PASSION
TO GO TO MARKET AND SELL THIS
STUFF WITH THE SAME PASSION
THAT YOU HAVE
FOR RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT.
I'M SORRY, ROBERT.
I'D LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU,
BUT THAT'S JUST --
THAT'S MORE EQUITY THAN I'M
PREPARED TO GIVE UP RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW THIS IS NOT THE LAST
MONEY I'M GONNA HAVE TO RAISE.
AND IF I GIVE UP
A THIRD OF THE COMPANY NOW,
THERE WON'T BE ENOUGH LEFT
IN THE TANK TO GET THERE.
THAT'S AN $8.5 MILLION VALUATION
ROBERT JUST MADE YOU,
AND YOU'VE PASSED ON THAT.
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE OFFER, ROBERT,
BUT, AT THAT LEVEL OF EQUITY,
I-I CAN'T ACCEPT.
I'M SORRY.
LOOK, CHRIS YOU MADE
AN EDUCATED GUESS, IF YOU WILL,
ON WHAT
THE BEST VALUATION IS.
THERE'S A LONG WAY TO GO.
IF EVERYTHING YOU'RE SAYING
IS TRUE IN TERMS OF COMPETITION,
$50 MILLION VALUATION
IS UNDERSELLING YOURSELF
DRAMATICALLY, RIGHT?
THE -- THE TECHNOLOGY
IS ONLY GONNA GET BETTER.
YOU'RE ONLY GONNA IMPROVE
THE PRODUCT.
I JUST CAN'T MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS RIGHT NOW.
AND TO JUST THROW $3 MILLION
AT IT AND HOPE I GOT IT RIGHT --
IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE VALUATION.
IT'S ABOUT
THE RISK/REWARD.
AND SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
CHRISTOPHER.
YOU'RE SAYING NO TO 35%.
I'M GONNA --
I'M GONNA NEGOTIATE
AGAINST MYSELF.
I MEAN, THAT'S HOW INTERESTED
I AM IN THIS.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $3 MILLION
FOR 25% WITH EQUAL
REPRESENTATION ON THE BOARD.
THAT'S MY FINAL OFFER.
YOU GOT A DEAL.
ALL RIGHT.
Cuban: THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU. YEAH.
WOW. GO, ROBERT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
I KEEP THE DEAD BODY.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'LL MAKE YOU
A SPECIAL ONE.
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S $40,000 WORTH
OF INVENTORY.
Sakezles: WELL, ROBERT'S
ALWAYS BEEN MY FAVORITE.
WE'RE BOTH TECHIES.
THIS INVESTMENT WILL ULTIMATELY
ALLOW US TO SAVE
A LOT OF ANIMALS' LIVES,
A LOT OF PEOPLE'S LIVES,
AND DO A LOT OF GOOD
IN THE WORLD.
I THINK IT'S GONNA BE GREAT.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
HIRE A C.E.O. FOR HIM?
YEAH.
HE NEEDS SOMEBODY
WHO'S GONNA RUN THE BUSINESS.
ABSOLUTELY.
HE IS THE CLASSIC EXAMPLE
OF A BRILLIANT GUY
THAT NEEDS A C.E.O.
EARLY ON.
DEFINITELY.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU --
ARE YOU GONNA TAKE AN INSURANCE
POLICY OUT ON THE SCIENTIST.
I DON'T THINK
HE'S GONNA MAKE IT MUCH LONGER.
HE HARDLY HAS A HEARTBEAT.
THE CADAVER HAS MORE ENERGY
THAN THAT GUY.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A COMPANY THAT WANTS
TO BRING OUT THE SUPERHERO
IN EVERYONE.
HI, SHARKS.
I AM ALESIA GLIDEWELL BY DAY.
AND BY NIGHT,
I AM THE HERO CREATRIX.
I'M KERI ANDREWS,
ALSO KNOWN AS TRANSFORMA GIRL.
OUR COMPANY IS BASED
IN SEATTLE, WASHINGTON,
AND WE ARE ASKING
FOR $100,000
IN RETURN
FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
A HERO IN EVERYONE
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE INTRODUCING
OUR COMPANY, YOU KICK ASS,
THAT TRANSFORMS YOU
INTO YOUR VERY OWN
PERSONALIZED
ACTION FIGURE.
SO, THE VERY FIRST THING
YOU HAVE TO DO IS
JUST PICK OUT
YOUR BODY STYLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THEN YOU UPLOAD A SINGLE
PHOTOGRAPH TO OUR WEBSITE.
OH, YEAH. OH, YEAH!
OH, NO!
THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
MORE LIKE MR. EGGHEAD
OVER THERE.
MR. WONDERFUL.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS UPLOAD THAT PHOTO,
AND OUR SOFTWARE WILL TURN IT
INTO A 3-D MODEL OF YOUR HEAD.
WHAT HAPPENED
TO HIS HAIR?
Cuban: OH, THERE IT IS!
[ LAUGHTER ]
ANYWAY, SO, YOU LINE IT UP
WITH YOUR FACIAL FEATURES,
AND THEN YOU GET TO PICK OUT
SOME FUN THINGS,
LIKE YOUR HAIR
AND ACCESSORIES.
Herjavec: THAT'S COOL.
Glidewell: PINK IS TRENDING.
GOOD-LOOKING HERO.
WE PRINT OUT A 3-D MODEL
OF YOUR HEAD WITH THIS
AND THEN WE ATTACH IT
TO YOUR BODY.
AND THEN
WE SEND IT TO YOU.
HOW REAL DOES IT LOOK
ONCE IT ACTUALLY COMES OUT?
OH, GLAD YOU ASKED.
YEAH.
ARE YOU READY TO SEE YOURSELVES
AS HEROES?
YES.
ALL RIGHT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, MY GOSH,
IT LOOKS EXACTLY LIKE ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOW.
OH, I LOVE MINE.
I LOVE IT.
I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE FACE BUT --
OH, YEAH.
AND WHAT'S AMAZING IS
THE BODY IS EXACTLY --
EXACTLY, I KNOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I MEAN,
YOU GOT THE BODY DOWN.
WE ACTUALLY PICKED OUT
SOME SUPERPOWERS FOR YOU...
OH.
...AND NAMES,
SO, ROBERT, YOU HAVE
THE POWER OF SUPER SPEED,
AND YOU ARE THE ACCELERATOR.
OOH, THE ACCELERATOR!
I LIKE IT.
Andrews: LORI, YOU HAVE
IMAGINATION MANIFESTATION,
AND YOU ARE ENCHANTRA.
OH, I LOVE IT.
ENCHANTRA!
Glidewell: KEVIN, YOU HAVE
A POWER I WOULD LIKE,
WHICH IS THE POWER
OF WINE MANIPULATION.
AND WE CALLED YOU
THE VINIFICATOR.
Cuban: THE VINIFICATOR!
WOW.
BARBARA, YOU HAVE PRECOGNITION,
AND YOU ARE THE HUNCH.
MM.
Glidewell:
AND, MARK, YOU HAVE THE POWER
OF SUPERHUMAN INTUITION,
OF COURSE I DO.
AND YOU ARE
THE GAME CHANGER!
YEAH, THAT'S WHAT'S UP,
BABY.
I HAD TO DO THAT.
HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THE IDEA?
OKAY, SO, I USED TO BE
A VOICEOVER ARTIST
AND A MOTION-CAPTURE
MODEL.
OH, WOW.
SO, I GOT THE LUCKY OPPORTUNITY
OF BEING THE MODEL
FOR A CHARACTER
IN A VIDEO GAME.
AND THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS,
I LEARNED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT 3-D MODELING AND HOW
THEY TAKE PHOTOGRAPHS OF YOU
AND BASICALLY TURN IT
INTO A MODEL.
MY BACKGROUND IS
IN WEBSITE DEVELOPMENT
AND ALSO
IN DIGITAL MARKETING.
BEFORE QUITTING
MY FULL-TIME JOB AT MICROSOFT
TO START THIS COMPANY --
WHAT DID YOU DO AT MICROSOFT?
I WAS WORKING
FOR THE BING SEARCH ENGINE.
I REALLY GOT LEARN
THE INS AND OUTS
OF HOW SEARCH ENGINES WORK
AND HOW TO DRIVE CUSTOMERS
TO WEBSITES.
SO, HAVE YOU SOLD
ANYTHING?
WE HAVEN'T GONE
TO MARKET YET.
YOU HAVEN'T?
WE JUST, LITERALLY,
A MONTH AGO FINISHED
THE CROWDFUNDING CAMPAIGN.
OOH.
Greiner: OH, OKAY.
SO, YOU HAVEN'T SOLD ANY.
DO YOU KNOW, THOUGH,
WHAT IT WOULD COST YOU
TO MAKE ONE AND WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING OF SELLING IT FOR?
Andrews: OH, YES.
SURE. IT COSTS $15,
AND WE SELL THEM FOR $60.
WHAT'S THE CAPACITY
YOU HAVE?
WE CAN PRINT ABOUT 100 A DAY
PER 3-D PRINTER.
WHAT DO
THE PRINTERS COST?
IF THEY'RE NEW, $45,000.
WE HAVE BOUGHT BOTH OF OURS USED
FOR ABOUT $20,000.
IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
THAT MAKES SOMETHING SIMILAR?
IS THERE ANY COMPETITION?
SURE, THERE A COUPLE
OF OTHER COMPANIES
THAT MAKE
PERSONALIZED ACTION FIGURES.
HOW ARE THEY DOING? ARE THEY --
ARE THEY BIG COMPANIES?
THEY'RE SMALL.
THEY'RE ALL SMALL.
WE DID A LOT
OF MARKET RESEARCH
BEFORE EVEN ENTERING
INTO THIS SPACE.
ONCE YOU DID
THAT RESEARCH,
WHO DID YOU DECIDE
WAS YOUR BEST CUSTOMER?
THE BEST CUSTOMERS ARE AGED
ABOUT 30 TO 45.
OH, REALLY?
MEN, WOMEN?
SO, YOU'RE NOT THINKING
OF THIS FOR CHILDREN.
ACTUALLY,
WE WERE GOING INTO THIS
EXPECTING THAT MORE PEOPLE WERE
GONNA WANT TO BUY THEM FOR KIDS.
AND OVERWHELMINGLY,
WE FOUND THAT PEOPLE WANTED
TO BUY THESE
FOR OTHER ADULTS.
SOMEBODY REACHED OUT AND SAID
HE WAS BUYING ONE FOR HIS WIFE
FOR BEING A SUPER MOM.
OH, THAT'S CUTE.
SOMEBODY ELSE REACHED OUT,
SAID SHE'S BUYING ONE
FOR HER AUNT
WHO HAD JUST SURVIVED
BREAST CANCER.
RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT.
I THINK IT'S VERY CLEVER.
NOW I'M TRYING TO THINK --
HOW DO YOU CONTINUE TO SCALE
AND BUILD COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGES?
RIGHT.
IS THERE ANYTHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING?
THE THING
WITH 3-D PRINTING --
IT IS A NEW TECHNOLOGY,
RIGHT?
AND SO THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF SOFTWARE OUT THERE
THAT IS AVAILABLE
TO SUPPORT,
ESPECIALLY
FULL-COLOR 3-D PRINTING.
AND SO WE BUILT
OUR OWN SOFTWARE,
WHICH IS PATENT-PENDING.
HOW MUCH DID YOU INVEST
IN THIS?
AND IS IT ALL YOU MONEY?
IT'S ALL OUR MONEY, AND SO FAR,
WE'VE PUT IN
ABOUT $120,000.
Corcoran: KERI,
CAN I ADDRESS THE RESEMBLANCE?
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THESE HEADS LOOK LIKE US.
I DON'T THINK
THAT LOOKS LIKE ME.
LOOK AT KEVIN.
OTHER THAN THE FACT
THAT THAT'S A BALD HEAD,
I WOULD NOT SAY THAT
THAT RESEMBLED KEVIN.
THAT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE MARK.
SO I'M CONCERNED.
BUT SHE'S RIGHT, THOUGH.
IT'S AN ISSUE.
Corcoran: THE SEAM
ON THE NECK -- IS THAT A MUST?
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU CHOPPED OFF A HEAD
AND STUCK ANOTHER HEAD
ON THERE.
IT'S NOT WELL-MATCHED,
THE COLORATION,
NOR IS THE SPACING GOOD.
Corcoran: KERI,
CAN I ADDRESS THE RESEMBLANCE?
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THESE HEADS LOOK LIKE US.
I DON'T THINK
THAT LOOKS LIKE ME.
I WOULD NOT SAY THAT
THAT RESEMBLED KEVIN.
THAT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE MARK.
SO I'M CONCERNED.
BUT SHE'S RIGHT THOUGH.
IT'S AN ISSUE.
I TAKE EXCEPTION
TO THE QUALITY ISSUE
AND THE SEAM
ON THE NECK.
Andrews: HERE'S THE THING --
YOU KNOW, FIRST --
FIRST,
THERE'S ONLY ONE COMPANY
THAT MAKES
THE FULL-COLOR 3-D PRINTERS,
AND SO THERE IS
SOME LIMITATIONS
WHEN IT COMES TO JUST
THE DETAIL THAT CAN BE PRINTED.
PRECISION, RIGHT?
BUT THE PRECISION IS KEY
TO THE SALE ON THIS.
AND UNTIL
THAT'S PERFECTED,
I THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE
A LOT OF RETURNS.
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I DON'T SEE THAT.
MY FIRST REACTION
WHEN YOU GAVE IT TO ME
WAS, "WOW, IT REALLY LOOKS
A LOT LIKE ME."
OF COURSE YOU'RE GONNA FIND
FAULT WITH IT,
BUT IT'S A GIFT.
MM-HMM.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
I AM THE ACCELERATOR.
YES.
SO I LIKE THE IDEA.
I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF CHALLENGES.
SURE.
I REALLY DO.
BUT I THINK
YOU'LL GET THERE.
I MEAN, YOU GUYS HAVE
A GREAT BACKGROUND.
BUT OBVIOUSLY,
I SEE RISK.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $100,000 FOR 25%.
THAT'S, UH --
I'D LIKE TO HEAR
IF THERE ARE OTHER OFFERS.
WHAT COMES NEXT
FOR YOU GUYS?
ONE OF THE THINGS WE SEE
THAT THE SOFTWARE CAN BE
OUR COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE.
IN ADDITION TO
THOSE PERSONALIZED CHARACTERS,
WE WANT TO EXPLORE DIGITAL
PRODUCTS WITH THE SOFTWARE,
WHERE YOU COULD USE
THE -- THE 3-D HEAD
WITHOUT NECESSARILY
NEEDING TO
PHYSICALLY PRINT OUT
AN OBJECT.
AS A CONSUMER,
WHAT WOULD I DO WITH THAT?
YOU COULD DO...
MAKING AN AVATAR
THAT LOOKS LIKE ME?
YOU COULD DO AVATARS
AND --
YOU COULD TURN IT
INTO GAME PIECES.
YEAH, IN HIGH-END GAMES,
YOU COULD.
GAMES.
I THINK THAT'S FRINGE
SORT OF VERSUS --
NO, NO.
THAT'S ACTUALLY
PROBABLY BIGGER BUSINESS.
I DON'T KNOW.
[ LAUGHS ]
WHEN LOW-COST
COLOR PRINTERS COME OUT,
ONE OF THE THINGS PEOPLE
ARE GONNA WANT TO DO
IS EMULATE THEMSELVES,
AND THERE WILL BE OTHER APPS
THAT WILL DO THAT.
SO I THINK
YOU HAVE TO RUN, LIKE,
VERY FAST
TO GET SOME MARKET SHARE
WITH A BRAND
THAT PEOPLE KNOW.
AND I'M GONNA MAKE
THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE MARGINS
IS GONNA GET SHRUNK
PRETTY QUICKLY
AS OTHERS COMPETE.
YOU PUT HERE
A $1 MILLION VALUATION --
IT'S AGGRESSIVE.
BUT I'LL DO 100K.
I'M GONNA TAKE $10
OFF OF EVERY DOLL
UNTIL I RECOUP THE 100K,
AND THEN IT'S GONNA DROP
TO $2.50 IN PERPETUITY,
AND I'M GETTING 5% EQUITY.
SO I'M VALUING
YOUR BUSINESS TODAY...
TRY TO REPEAT THAT.
...AT $2 MILLION.
THAT'S, LIKE,
ONE OF YOUR WORST ONES.
SO I'M SAYING
YOU'RE WORTH $2 MILLION TODAY --
TWICE WHAT YOU ASKED FOR.
BUT I'M PUTTING
A STRUCTURE IN PLACE
THAT RECOUPS MY MONEY
BEFORE I THINK
THE MARGINS GET CRUSHED.
AND I'M SAYING
YOU'LL FIGURE IT OUT.
WE'LL FIGURE IT OUT TOGETHER
'CAUSE I HAVE AN INCENTIVE
TO STAY IN THE GAME.
HE JUST WENT
FROM BEING A SUPERHERO
TO BEING A SUPER-ZERO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OKAY, I'M GONNA
MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I DON'T SEE YOU GUYS AS
A MANUFACTURING COMPANY PER SE.
I CAN PROBABLY SEE YOU,
HOPEFULLY,
AS A TECHNOLOGY COMPANY...
MM-HMM.
...THAT CAN TAKE YOUR SOFTWARE
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $100,000 FOR 10%...
...BUT I WANT TO KNOW NOW
'CAUSE I DON'T WANT TO DEAL
WITH THESE GUYS.
YES OR NO?
I'LL --
I'LL TAKE THAT.
I'LL TAKE IT, TOO.
LET'S GO.
LET'S DO IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
THAT'S EXCITING.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU.
OH, NO, IT'S EXCITING.
THIS IS GONNA BE AWESOME.
WE'LL DO SOME STUFF
WITH THE MAVS.
WE'LL HELP YOU
WITH THE SOFTWARE.
WE'LL HAVE
A LOT OF FUN.
OKAY, AWESOME. THANK YOU.
THANKS, GUYS.
BY THE WAY,
I LIKED MY OFFER MUCH BETTER.
THANK YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GOOD LUCK.
I'M GONNA TAKE MY SUPERHERO,
AND I'M GOING HOME.
[ LAUGHS ]
Andrews: WE WENT WITH MARK
BECAUSE WE FELT LIKE
HE WOULD BE
A GREAT PARTNER.
HE REALLY SEEMED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'RE A TECHNOLOGY COMPANY,
AND HE GAVE US
WHAT WE ASKED FOR.
I-I COULDN'T BE
MORE EXCITED.
YEAH.